a truck what truck guys like what but
but so let me see that I like a bit of
you to go deliver though that song Hong
Kong Kong uh were there other lyrics
that song passenger side best friend
right try to holler at me with just said
coach me there's a very very right I
don't know any of these words away your
pain something something insane she will
do things living la vida loca she push
and pull
hot wax
oh [ __ ] yeah this is my jam
being swing we do the thing and thing
and wingnut I'll wear the flower dress
and you'll something [ __ ] [ __ ] I listen
I literally listen to this song like
every other day currently - me how did
the bearded daylight leave me down by
the moonlit cold Oh people can't sing at
basketball game something silver moons
sparkling drums drums drums so kiss me I
don't know
Tara Betty a dash of Sandra Peggy a
little bit of Toni in my mind a little
bit of that's against Who I am a little
bit of Miss guy in my family bit of you
makes me your man what an amazing
distress they'll do five for this that
there's that none of this some of this
one of this what of this rap news just
goin straight to the wow wow oh I don't
know this at all well I think I did
amazing
all that girly versus gold only shooting
stars sprinkles and smalls that can't be
right